foreign
[Music]
this could be my biggest challenge ever
I'm checking into The Priory 100-seater
restaurant desperately in need of rehab
[__] at its best it served the most
disgusting food I've ever come across
what's in here that's a broccoli soup
looks like vomit with one of the worst
kitchen brigades I've encountered
I'm one of the most naive owners I've
met
we're so [__] annoyed with just five
days to turn it around there's Rebels
going cold turkey and today we're
stopping we're shutting it down and
we're starting again
[Music]
hey what's Heath a wealthy town in the
heart of West Sussex
close to London it's plus with young
fashionable commuters and Rich
professionals looking for a flash meal
out
a really exciting environment little
town everything's here Banks restaurants
Brands I have to say absolutely ideal
for a local good renowned restaurants
[Music]
but the age of Priory isn't attracting
the Young And Hip
it's more Saga holiday than Club 1830.
the restaurant stuck in a Time Warp
turning out old-fashioned carvery every
day for the past 20 years like a sausage
yes
thank you at home you know you never
have a big joint and it's really lovely
to have something off a really nice big
joint
former I.T consultant Scott hson Brought
The Priory six weeks ago for 300 Grand
he's acquired a business losing 5 000 a
week but what the hell he's ended up
with a beautiful building I've always
really wanted to to be a restaurant
Turtle I guess this place has got so
much character so much charm that you
know I don't think I can fail to ever
Tire of walking through that restaurant
with those windows you know it's just
amazing
[Music]
couple of a 19th century Convent The
Priory certainly is a Heavenly venue
bangers are swearing
God it's beautiful
very Gothic
[Music]
sister Wendy is about to jump me
it's beautiful
here's the vicar hello good afternoon
it's a pleasure to me and you are the
I'm the owner good to see what a
beautiful place
amazing it's magnificent that's
beautiful and the country's been here
for 20 years yes so it's almost sort of
the heartbeat of the restaurant yeah
it's the tradition around here if you
talk to people about the prior in how
your teeth then they would you know
they'll say oh yeah I've been there but
they've all been for carvery never been
to a car ring for ages last time I went
I think it was back in 1982 called The
Bernie Inn and it's a Sunday lunch and
it was [__] ghastly
Ferrari's food must be denture friendly
this place is rammed with the blue Rings
Brigade I'm the youngest here by miles
it's almost like they've opened a soup
kitchen for the elderly and it's a sort
of glamorous old people's home
but my age concern is explained when the
golden oldies keep turning up with
suspicious looking vouchers from the
local papers we offer two meals surprise
one it's 9.99 for is that for that's
real car right if you put a discount on
9.99 we do so much discount
um please buy one get one free
um
so you eat here for five
um yes I'm starting to feel left out am
I the only one here without a voucher
too
did you bring your voucher today yes yes
did you bring your coupon
um
I mean it's cheaper to come here than it
is cooking at home oh yes definitely
yeah it's just really marvelous value
you must have dementia to only let half
your punters pay no wonder this business
is losing money
the food's a bargain assuming's up to
scratch
Toby's the priorities head chef this
claim to fame was a stint at Planet
Hollywood he's the Starship Trooper in
charge of the carvery
his sidekick Bob is the part-time
carvery Chef right what have we got you
got turkey here yes right you've got
um
River Beef Pork and lamb
so these are done every day these are
every day yeah
[Music]
found with an orange juice and it's
rather nice though to sell us Peach and
nut and with orange juice
okay
holy mackerel
geez they're all out for a Fiverr yeah
just enjoy it going
first potatoes cooked to [__] and
stuffing that was like sort of trying to
cut through a silicone implant
and it
I'm doing
Yorkshire pudding well
soggy and turkey well
I just don't try tasty
even the quality of the beef
we're still stuck in the doldrums here
and all of that today so far
[__]
[__] at its best
Scots certainly got himself a Celestial
building but that pitiful excuse of a
carvery is a mortal sin
okay Mets
I haven't met hi Matt Matt good to see
you um you do general manager channel
manager owner general manager and you
must be the kitchen manager
and what are you buddy I generally do
the general cooking of the veg in
general
rights around the kitchen okay this man
we met you look so different with your
house I know yeah can I see you buddy
I'm Tom Tom and what'd you do I'm a
trainee Chef training Chef excellent
good and you're studying uh cooking good
and this is Toby
and you're completely responsible for
everything that goes on the Whole
Foods sometimes so you're a chef as well
I've trained as a chef here oh I'm good
to go yeah so proper all-round general
manager oh I'd like to think so yeah I
was really excited when I walked it I
was seriously walked up the stairs with
Christ it's quite breathtaking walking
through that door and unfortunately
there's a carvery it was dry it was
hideous it was overcooked and it tasted
of nothing sat alongside plastic
Yorkshire puddings that I wouldn't even
use as a [__] ice hockey pot I mean
you know as a chapter Chef right let's
be honest you can't call yourself a chef
if you sell that [__] and I'm not just
blaming you I've got to bring in the
general manager yeah yeah
it's just important to blame of course I
do yeah but you know it it was bad I
mean the whole experience was bad then
you look around and you look at the
customers
half of them were beaten for nothing
uh yeah on yeah on the buy one get on
free vouchers that have been in place
historically to attract people through
the door the spend per head is very low
because it's more important than dying
off aren't they
well yeah I was the youngest one in
there about 40 years today the first
time I was sat in [__] a dying room
and felt so young
we're going down quickly yet no one
seems to realize how quickly we are
sinking
[__] me there's some cobwebs that need
blasting here I'll tell you
[Music]
Ferrari's 100-seater restaurants in an
old Convent and it's full of bad habits
the venue's Heavenly but head chef
Toby's food Straight From Hell
rookie restaurant Scott HSN bought a
business losing a fortune with food
given away in vouchers I'm the priory's
last chance of Salvation it's my
toughest task yet
tonight the rest is gonna be absolute
absolutely with the 241 Vash Brigade so
Toby's gonna be busy it'll give me a
chance to see him in action how can
professional chefs struggle to get a
simple carvery out twice a day
what the [__] is he doing
eating Toby's lunch was like chewing
carpet but it's no wonder when all I can
find in his fridge are old half eaten
joints set to be used again
what are we gonna do with that feel that
it's rock hard yeah I know and it
usually goes in the bin because get so
many covers at the moment so how many of
them do you put in the bin roughly
three a week
maybe so right now you've got a meat
Mountain yeah I use up your sandwiches
somewhere if it's any good we put it
back out [__] me what's that those we
won't use but what's that
lamb loud
you know you're me don't you
especially when it's [__] rotten look
at it
I think you're not being very honest
with me now you know that no don't go
off
the turkey breast it's still warm and
that's
three hours ago
what happens when you wrap things in
climb film when they're still warmed
come on it still carries on bacteria and
all the rest of it that's right so it
cools down and stays hot inside cools
down the outside and Festus and the
bacteria grows in you put it back out on
the carvery not very often no but some
of the time yes we do
this is page one of Food hygiene even my
most Junior Chef would know that this is
dangerous practice if this stuff goes
out we're all dead meat but how are Toby
starters
that's a broccoli soup that's broccoli
soup no it's not broccoli soup it needs
to thicken up I haven't got round to
well okay I didn't think enough
yesterday looks like vomit
I'm not finished the whole thing so you
are a lazy [__] you know
oh yeah what I'm saying I haven't had
time to finish it why not all right I
did have time but I never got around to
finishing it off do me a big favor
I can ditch it
Toby's incompetence is Flushing The
Priory down the plug hole I've never met
such a gormless head chef if his prep is
this bad Lord help us with the rest of
service right so Toba your cheese sauce
let's play The Recipe comes out of
packets
bastard
so no not you my oven
so all the veggies prepped no just the
carrots and the potatoes come in prepped
up this is more expensive this way
yes
are they hot inside and I'll put them in
the oven you steam them
wow why are they soaking wet look at the
sponge there
awesome it's like King Kong's [__]
condom look at it
this is [__] horrendous personally
I've never quite seen anything of that
[__] nut
the [__] meat is cooked for hours and
stuck in a hot cupboard to go dry run up
to the [__] carvery the sauces are
from a [__] packet the Yorkshire
puddings are frozen and then the chef is
totally oblivious to what he's [__]
serving
upstairs the meals and wheels Brigade
aren't bellyaching but then who would
when they're giving it away
two meals for the price of one out of
tenor that's got to be less than it cost
to put it on a plate
Matt's the general manager I know the
prior is in purgatory he thinks
restaurant novice Scots Mata bought the
business
it's got so many uh potential failings
in it and huge costs to keep it running
if you've never run a restaurant before
then this probably wouldn't be your
number one choice but it certainly
wouldn't be mine but Scott's drowning
parading stiffly in his suit and tie
he's more Bank Clark than passionate
restaurateur this man's in way over his
head I don't think you quite understand
how bad it is you may have one of the
most beautiful [__] stunning dining
rooms in Britain today I'll agree with
you on that one but [__] me this is one
of the worst kitchens I've ever been in
and then I'm [__] looking at you
thinking
how can you let all this go on under
your nose with the Instinct that you
have for business and not understand
that this [__] place is going down
the path there's so many things that
I've looked at and said this is all
wrong it's where to start
right now it's worse than Hospital foods
and we're not cooking we're not on
carvery we're a [__] mess
tomorrow morning
I want to see you and your team at 9 30.
because I can't go any further unless we
make some radical changes
it's now my second day at The Priory and
I need to act swiftly after the horrors
of last night's service I decide to raid
the kitchen early before the staff
arrive
d
Jesus Christ what is that
bloody hell
[__] you know
[__] you know how old is that
it's been there since [__] 1981. look
at it
the smell bingo
[__] you know
parsnips
look at them
what is that
what's that for
you can't cook in this
you can't even attempt to start thinking
of a new menu the only thing to do now
to condemn the [__] kitchen
[__] disgusting shut him down no way
anything is going to be [__] cooked
in here
I [__] hate here
[Music]
dirty [__] lazy pigs
ouch you're gonna learn the hard way big
boy
thank you
it's [__] closed
[Music]
carvery
my [__] ass I'm covering my ass what
other [__] is
coming this morning condemning the
kitchen's a last resort but for this
clueless Bunch it's a kick up the ass
they need but it won't be as half as
painful as a bollocking I'm about to
give them it's amazing have a good look
around
Matt
let's go
back there that came out of there
put all the veg in there like that last
night not rats
last names that you can tie a knot in
[__] cauliflower that's got mold in
it what's going on guys
we're all responsible for what we put in
the fridge yeah come on just hold my
hands upset which isn't just me that's
not good enough Toby
you forget your [__] fat head outside
your ass and start understanding what
the [__] is going on here
Scott I'm not your voice
I'm not here to blow smoke up your ass
this is your responsibility you've
bought into this and you've taken this
on your shoulders
absolutely we've I've had this
conversation with the guys a couple of
weeks ago about cleaning this kitchen up
but getting it ready for service Scott
you have to get real
you have got to get real
real I'm so [__] annoyed this is
disgusting Matt you may come in one day
a week two days a week whatever but give
me something will you you're a chef you
trained as a chef yeah well rumor has it
the food's [__] 10 times better when
you're cooking that's the rumors
well I'd like to think I wouldn't leave
the kitchen in that state no no I'll
have to go around and get 50 of those
customers last night [__] knock on
the door this morning and [__] walk
them in this kitchen
I just can't understand why you guys
left it like a [__]
knowing that Gordon was coming back this
morning that wrecks my head even more
than anything
I'm getting some fresh air because I
feel sick
unfucking believable I mean absolutely
disgusting most yes I know would be
[__] embarrassed for what I've just
done to that kitchen and Toby well he
didn't even [__] react Scott well
that guy's just sunk 300 Grand into this
[__] [__] he's oblivious and
that's for Matt well he seemed to be the
only one that actually cares he's deeply
embarrassed cannot believe the [__] in
that kitchen
it's time for a meeting with a bank
manager Scott's only been in the
restaurant trade for six weeks but he
won't last long at this rate I've been
running restaurants for 15 years and to
succeed you must have passion I need to
inject something to stuffy scart moving
almost the house how worried are you
yeah I'm very worried because it's my
it's my livelihood on the line it's my
career it's my family that I'm putting
on the line for the success of this
business you've just you've treaded
water yeah last two months yeah I accept
that but again you know it's my my lack
of understanding of the business if I
was already a successful restaurant to
her I could have come in here and said
right now I understand the business this
is what I expect a restaurant to run
like you run with me or go and find
another job but but it doesn't stop you
going around looking at [__] things
and checking under the [__] fridge
and asking the chef you know what the
[__] going on because you can't just
walk in like a vicar and be nice to
everybody Welcome them thanks for coming
up to work uh yeah I'm [__] paying
you my house is the security that's
guaranteeing your salary
[Music]
I pray Scott's sins will be forgiven but
to save The Priory it's his staff I need
to pardon my confession was used by the
prize Catholic nuns and perhaps a few
Hail Marys could help the kitchen crew
Purge their sins
what's the worst thing ever seen here
ever
same
I'd have to say meet getting taken out
of the oven dropped on the floor picked
up quickly put back on the hot tray put
in the hot cupboard I just don't want
the carvery to collapse or the priority
to collapse
it has collapsed yeah and it's losing
money
between four and five thousand a week
so I don't know who's telling you pork
is but
the Carver is [__] for the priorities
in the [__]
does a car being frustrating
sometimes yes
because it's just the same thing day
after day
mundane
perhaps probably after the problem
what nice is it no
I'm bringing it out the freezer for
Yorkshire pudding
why have you tried to do anything about
it
because I've just gotten a rut
they're so desperately
big boy
hey I'm here to help you all right
with the kitchen centers absolved
general manager Matt needs to unburden
himself he's also a cardinal sinner in
my eyes
how to motivate staff as a general
manager
probably not very well at the moment
because I'm probably demotivated and
deflated myself in all honesty
how hungry are you to make it work
very much very much indeed I've always
said I treat this like my own business
which sounds really [__] stupid
sitting here
uh in the in the state that we're in at
the moment
you wanted to succeed though don't you
yeah I do yeah I care about it and I
don't want to yeah
I don't want it to uh go the way it's
going gone
The Priory staff are so stuck in a rut
and it's the carvery that's the problem
I need to re-light the fire in these
guys with A New Concept that will excite
them and appeal to the younger wealthier
crowd to fill that 100-seater venue I
receive this packed with African
individuals the place is littered with
restaurants but what it hasn't got is a
good honest Grill personally ditch the
[__] carvery get rid of the festering
meat and out with the old in within you
and get hold of some good local honest
produce and cook it simply nothing more
than that
[Music]
this local Farm Supplies my restaurants
with beef and it's going to answer our
prayers I've invited the team along to
brief them on my idea that The Priory
should become a grill
some people just can't help putting
their foot in it Toby watch out for the
cow pack I'm worried about those you
can't [__] miss them look at them are
they beautiful
this is some of the best home reared
beef in the country and we have got it
wrong at The Priory
what we need to do now at The Priory is
to ditch the carvery and turn that
restaurant into a grill supplied locally
with phenomenal beef that starts at the
top of the menu
I'm hoping that getting hands on with
this Prime stock will motivate the team
all right who'd like to ride it let's
hope you go first
to help me Inspire the guys I've invited
a meat expert to test them on their cuts
of beef
so the sirloin is where
down there sirloin basically starts
there
and you can't back in one two three ribs
of the year of the 13 rib rib cage that
Toby where is the brisket
comes from the back end where
it's about there the brisket runs from
the first five ribs parallel underneath
it's probably like Matt where would we
get the top side from
embarrassingly so I haven't got a bloody
clue I have an educated guess well I
hope it's going to be at the top
somewhere for a start these guys are
more denser than Mensa but at last
they're getting to grips with great beef
Scott think about this one I know you're
not a chef you're an I.T consultant yeah
show me where you would get the oxtail
from
I think
well if I roll my sleeve huh
100 accurate
back at The Priory I've thrown out the
old kitchen and had six thousand pounds
of impressive new grill kit installed
along with a new chipper we can now hit
the ground running and stay
money
wow look at that beautiful a proper
grill a proper fryer there's no excuse
now
got the suit should be embracing the
grill with gusto but face to face with
it he loses his bottle his attitude is
getting to me what you've got to
understand is I am you know you do
understand I'm new to the business so
it's a radical radical change for what
I've seen has been here already for 20
years the Carver and it's it's been the
cash cow for the business to kind of
suddenly cut it off is obviously is a
concern but Scott what we've got to do
yeah you're losing five grand a week
yeah there's no cash cow this is what
this is this is what you bought you've
bought a head [__]
well I wouldn't put it in those terms
but yeah okay I understand exactly what
you're saying okay so a restaurant
that's losing five grand a week four
grand a week what is it then
it's a business that needs turning
around it's the same phrase but just
used in a polite way it's [__] scars
you can't have it both ways you can't
step in New Territory and evolve and
become somewhat dynamic in what you're
trying to do yeah and it's still legal
Faith you've got two Matt I need a bit
of support here I need a hundred percent
of the bill being paid so as we don't
come in with a semi-diluted Insight that
our business is functioning yet we're
giving 50 of it away
you don't have to sell that to me
because seriously don't help me out no
I'm going to give you five minutes on
your own because I don't think you get
it
see you later okay
I can't believe Scott he's such a
[__] slippery eel for God's sake
embrace the grill get excited about it
grab it
and run with it it can become [__]
phenomenal
there's no halfway house here yeah
change or die
[Music]
I'm at The Priory in haywards Heath I've
ditched their carvery and installed a
brand new grill I'm desperate to reopen
tonight but novice restaurant tour Scots
lost his nerve now he slept on it I hope
he's embraced the idea otherwise it's
game over
pretty well I called the link yeah good
to see it yeah
have a seat thank you
now you've had a chance to sleep on it
yeah yeah first thought this morning
when you woke up
excited yes or [__] yourself
a little bit both a bit of both a bit
like being told and suddenly white says
she's pregnant right loads of excitement
thinking great news great news and then
suddenly the realization of okay how the
hell are we going to do this what are we
going to do where are we going forward
so yeah yeah but yeah really really
excited today massive opportunity to
move on the
front is now on the grill but tonight's
address rehearsal yeah exactly very
simple menu and let's charge for three
courses 20 quid
now that's not expensive and tonight for
the first time in the history of this
[__] restaurant we're not giving
anything away
these chefs aren't the sharpest knives
in the draw
so for this bunch I've deliberately
chosen a trial menu that's easy to
prepare and can be turned around in
large numbers
salad with some fresh chives yeah
yeah mixed another end yeah I smoke
mackerel fillets Bang
three so basically
vinaigrette round
and bang bingo
beerus salad feta pine nut and Rocket
what's that in there
found something interesting that's right
over
dress the beetroot
something fresh simple fragrant
how can we [__] that up
we can't really
the main courses will be rib eye steak
salmon and spatchcot chicken Toby's on
the grill
this menu and Grill don't take this the
wrong way but it's idiot proof
right yeah can you do that yeah
are you anxious I am yes good that's
healthy
no I don't want you to [__] it all up
either
Matt the general managers heading up the
front of house he's a trained Chef so he
can see the advantages of the grill God
knows about the rest of them I am
anxious that it is all going to work out
and it's completely diverse to what
we've done before
uh it's what we need to do
um and it's the only way forward out of
this carvery situation so
it'll be fine it'll be fine I'll keep
telling myself that
first customers are arriving for the
dress rehearsal dinner amongst them a
group of rather spiritual special guests
I've invited the bishop of Sussex to
head up a VIP table of local clergyman
if the kitchen stuff up at least they'll
Grant forgiveness
I've asked him to bless this kitchen and
how he may wish that we never see a
broccoli soup while you may yeah
anywhere near the building
Heavenly Father we thank you for the
gift of food to Delight us and to feed
us and we ask our blessing upon this
kitchen and these guys working here give
them a sense of Serenity in the midst of
the pressures they are under and we pray
a special blessing upon Gordon we know
he needs it and we ask you to bless his
kitchen the name of the father son and
holy spirit amen amen thank you sir
thank you
[Music]
okay
big secret
fill up those things fill them up fill
them up big enough yeah fill them up now
let it go right two covers one Caesar
salad to start a one smoked mackerel two
rib eyes one medium rare one medium two
chips two courses yes chef bingo
come on Bobby I need you tonight you
know that yeah yeah I know you're
waiting on a hip replacement but [__] me
hey I'm waiting on the [__] smoked
mackerel salad yeah
no because you put the balsamic vinegar
around there and it's just what's the
best Hollywood yeah that's what is oh
[__] me I can't believe it Bob screwed
up the dressing on the first dish
all Stuart's got to do is probably
courgettes and chips but this guy's on
another planet right what's going next
where's the courgettes please
[Music]
I honestly didn't realize taking chips
could be so [__] difficult
and as the all is Mount It's the Return
of the zombie on the grill Toby can't
run a kitchen and cook at the same time
again again [__] season them
salt pepper olive oil tray you can't
just throw a chicken on a [__] Grill
and expect it to [__] hey cook
the other season of the game oh [__]
sake kill us
try not to throw it on there yeah we're
[__] cooking we're not playing darts
with Toby screwing up he's now way
behind with the orders and two hours
into service tables are still waiting
for their food
go later
so we hope that we uh make a virtual
patient so absolutely we're not unhappy
it's one of the fruits of the spirit
tonight's menu is so simple any head
chef worthy salt should be able to cope
there's too much oil on there
too much oil on there
would you seriously that
hey
would you eat that
seriously no where are you at perfectly
honest I don't [__] know I'm going
down very fast I haven't got a [__]
clue at worst I'd hope Toby would muddle
through tonight but this guy clearly
isn't a head chef it's one Calamity
after another
hey
I'll do the pass yeah I'll Stand
alongside you and cook hey look at me
can you do it
give me five minutes five minutes three
minutes
three minutes yeah yeah
[__] you now look I was just burnt [__]
everywhere
going in pieces
don't know what happened there
right where's [__] Toby come on you
can't throw the towel in I can't believe
Toby's walked out he's letting everyone
down three bedroom Cellar two chicken
one salmon
no also
now even further behind with the orders
and the night's a disaster
[Music]
Scott's getting it in the net from the
customers just in a minute for the soap
yeah I understand that sorry about that
new menus the first night I understand
it's been challenging for you guys
you're not gonna yet
30 people out there do not want to play
for their dinner all right well I [__]
up that one so we're not doing 30 out of
50 we're doing like 30 out of 60.
that's what I've got up there telling me
it's not gonna pay for their dinner 30
people at the moment starters main
courses and desserts for 30 people ask
the [__] Bishop to take the place
over and help get him to hold a service
here on Sunday it'll be more [__]
successful
tonight's been a [__] disaster that
was bad
watching the first [__] 15 minutes
the way you organize your kitchen as far
as I'm concerned [__] midnight now
mate you're not capable of running a
[__] bath
okay
and then you disappear because you're
pissed off
I'm really sorry but tomorrow we're
going to readjust
if this place has got a chance to
[__] turn around Matt
I want you running the kitchen tomorrow
you have to concentrate tomorrow night
and all I want you to do is Cook
there's such an amazing opportunity here
[__] to turn this place around for
everyone to pull on the road and I get
an attitude like that
where's your spunk and [__] Pizzazz
so that you've got all this [__] new
stuff in here the roller coaster week
we've been on and and you just want to
[__] jerk off out the door because
it's [__] up tonight
we cannot give up we stay United one two
three four five six seven eight of you
have to come in here tomorrow morning as
a team just a [__] Dynamic team to
really want to do something [__]
different
restart
thank you
tough on that one last night Scott's
gonna have to understand if he wants to
turn this place around then he's gonna
have to invest in proper staff Toby is
not the head chef of the grill
I'm gonna focus in the kitchen today
with Matt and get some sort of power in
there some assertive strength hopefully
it should be a vast Improvement on last
night's service because that was a
[__] nightmare
with tonight's launch only hours away I
can't afford another disaster like last
night the stakes are even higher as I'm
introducing a bigger menu
rum steak revived fillet chicken lamb
tuna salmon so we've like almost sort of
doubled with Mata the helm control in
the kitchen it's a Gamble and I'm hoping
that the potential I've seen him will
pay off I like your assertiven if you
command a lot of sort of you know power
it's nice spread it around offload it on
them okay yeah yeah tough job
Priory menu completely revamped we've
got to get to get it out at the railway
station hundreds of City Slickers are
returning home they're just the wealthy
crowd I want eating at The Priory every
week now that the carbury's finally gone
steak sandwich come on don't be shy
I'm going to tempt them with some Prime
Steak and it's Scott's job to market the
grill and keep the campaign going anyone
heard of The Priory this is the relaunch
what do you think about steak sir
fantastic fresh new Innovative fantastic
food and we want all you guys in there
no it's a lovely pizza
oh [__] your what how can you do that
[Music]
it's launch night and the marketing
efforts pulling in a younger HIPAA crowd
to The Priory these are the people who
will help the business grow there's 80
books so we need to impress them to keep
them coming back so it's time to put a
rocket of these Space Cadets before
liftoff are we ready guys
yeah big night now I'm watching you like
a [__] [__] yeah I'm gonna be a
[__] CCT camera up your ass at all
yeah show me the grill
[Applause]
one more
show over the ground that's it excellent
Matt yeah too smooth to move
too smooth too space to move excellent
good luck make it work yes excellent
check on table 11 2 covers one macro one
meat one new potatoes two chips one
courgettes yes chef yes yeah good
tonight I'm leaving Matt to it there's
no more babysitting and these guys need
to show me they can step up to the plate
I want that Medium yeah looking pretty
Raw on the sides of me drop the [__]
griddle yeah yeah right three mackerel
please Tom yeah I need those next yeah
sure
Julie I really need those sides Bubba
what's your salmon
yeah table nine
it looks like it's [__] been
Mike Tyson yeah he's going cold Toby but
yeah well I've just [__] the sound
right hey hey big boy that's no way to
talk to the [__] gentleman where's
your respect
I'm getting that Groundhog Day Feeling
Matt really needs to hold the kitchen
together
upstairs and the restaurant the food is
getting out but there are glitches
sorry about the tuna whose was it
damn was it way overcooked yeah yeah
is that Sears that's what that one this
one no if nothing is on the grill that
one no nothing on the grill should I
call that and confuse you no I'll keep
it for a moment yeah
despite Toby's Tantrums Matt has a firm
grip on things and I'm impressed with
how he's keeping his cool
that's control of the kitchen is paying
off in the restaurant
at last the grill menu is going down
well I'm darling what did you have
salmon salmon it's very nice
are you missing the carvery no we've
been coming here for on and off for the
last 10 years
and I'm thinking it from around its
course yeah the carvery it's time for
insurance yeah this is excellent well
it's very common I'm glad you enjoyed it
I'm pleased to come back five days ago
the prior was churning out plates of
crap Carberry for a fiver tonight with
freshly cooked food from the grill the
restaurant's making money and the Vic is
almost enthusiastic 3 200 pounds we've
taken we did 80 covers tonight
um you know working that out through 80
covers that's 40 pounds ahead spend you
know clearly the concept of a Grill
Works you know I think it's going to be
very successful so that's very good so
I'm really you know kind of buzzing and
I'm tired from the week but you know
very excited
that's been The Priory savior tonight
his Trent kept the kitchen going despite
his flock's obvious flaws if you weren't
in the kitchen
tonight nothing will come out you are
the sole key individual that can be
instrumental at turning this [__]
business around I don't really mean that
thank you and so don't let go of that
strength I swear to God because if you
let it go they're all [__] now we've
done this tonight this is this is where
I wanted to go you know this is where we
are this is where we are going yeah as
far as I'm concerned well is that good
thank you cheers I'll see you in a month
yeah yeah and thank me I can't wait to
come back I'm dying to find out who's
gonna be the [__] head chef all right
going around um the difference from the
carvery to the grill night and day
um [__] me Scott has got an asset in
Matt and if he lets Matt do his job then
restart the kitchen Focus menus there
run with it because
it's hardly [__] rocket science
[Music]
it's six weeks since I was in hayward's
Heath I left the Priory grill with a
packed congregation making a healthy
profit
I'm back and I can't wait to find out
what the score is I'm hoping that Matt
has still got a grip of the kitchen and
Scott has been pushing the business
forward and getting the message out
there hey
hello everybody
how are you yeah you're still in the
kitchen I am good news very good news
Toby where is he day off Toby's gone
Toby's gone yeah
that's uh that's a positive decision
Toby was sacked for preparing chicken
that was off he disputes this but left
anyway so has the business taken off
how's it been
uh not busy enough ready seriously lunch
and dinner or
um we've probably done about 230 covers
or whereabouts every week is that all 2
30. Christ yeah we were doing on coffee
I spoke about seven 700 as an average
Christ so from 700 he lost 500 covers
comes down to advertising we're not
advertising what we're doing you know we
haven't we haven't said we're not a
carvery we've gone back to carvery on
the weekend carvery's back
one day a week guest appearance I just
think it's a massive massive golden
opportunity that we've potentially
[__] up so far
[__] so frustrating
unbelievable the car is back and the
business is failing what's the vicar
gone and done Scott how are you
yeah well thank you I was until I heard
the news we're down by 500 covers the
message is still not out there and the
carvery's come back I I think you made a
big mistake you were sending your
conflicted message by having a carving
on a Sunday why can't I just have a
simple roast and plate it
because that isn't what the customers
around here are telling me that they
want okay I'll get I'll be losing
confidence Scott no no it's not no it's
not about that Gordon it's a it's a it's
a dinosaur that [__] thing what
message have you put out there about a
grill
taking place I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
stand here and say we've got it all you
know everything's sorted out and we've
got it going are we ready to bring in 80
covers and do it well I don't think we
still are you could cope with on the
back of Dune 80 in front of me
with a [__] handicap [__] Brigade
you know no disrespect to Toby but you
know he didn't have the [__]
strongest [__] influence in the
kitchen I'm more confident six weeks
down the line you could be doing 150 on
a Saturday night I just think it's a
missed opportunity I'm infuriated with
Scott he's he's so weak-willed and he's
forgotten the lesson of the marketing
campaign I started at the rail station
I call an urgent meeting with his staff
to shock him into action your asset is
driving the [__] business
marketing selling your [__] business
and standing there like a [__]
salesman driving it and you've got to
loosen up and embrace your staff listen
to them and move forward together I
think sometimes that you're so [__]
worried about your persona in front of
them because of your weakness in the
industry I'm seriously trying to help
you do this Scott yeah seriously there
is no other
you know ultimatum kind of thing that
we're we're doing is to help do this and
make it run more smoothly we're going
out the street
today and we're gonna [__] drum up
some business
and ties are banned why what's wrong
with being smartly dressed and turned
out nothing should be smart
let me tell you yeah before you get all
[__] angry and take a swipe and [__]
me am I quick there's a level of
casualness when you've got an open neck
shirt rather than an office point of
view with a [__] shirt and tile are
you worried about the tie it's a nice
tie
off
yeah you can off as well
is it coming off
[Applause]
well that's better all right I'll take
my tile off
freed from the shackles of his suit and
tie Scott's gotta rev up his marketing
drive it's what he should have been
doing six weeks ago and now we need all
hands on deck
ready big smile
Mr Russian turn lead the way let's go
ladies
yesterday they had seven for dinner
tonight I want a full house yes
it's the young and Wealthy Scott needs
to attract they're the future for his
restaurant
and we've got a booking for you tonight
coming out of your real good
7 30. fantastic after less than an hour
the priori's hundred seats are filling
up
we're nearly fully booked tonight and
you still look unhappy I'm loving it
absolutely no I love it I love it I'm
not unhappy
yeah
spreading the good word on the streets
has paid off and tonight the Prairie is
full of customers
[Music]
has Scott finally repented for his
marketing sins yeah I've learned from
today that it's the you know it's the
marketing that's the most important
thing a lot of these people have never
been here before when they're out there
now arriving about it so yeah that's
absolutely what we need to do now
they're young they're vibrant and it's
exactly the kind of customers that you
deserve yeah drive it thank you yeah and
I mean drive it and don't stop driving
it yeah no exactly and not a one day
thing is it no ongoing no no no no no
and do me one more favor
yeah
I'll do another button good night
Scott now just needs to drive it
business doesn't just come and sit on
your lap you've got to go looking for it
and if you don't you're gonna fail
as a cocktail what's it called I need a
name trip
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
my mission this week the fishing anchor
owners Mike and Karen are a couple at
War
[Music]
their rails are legendary
they're driving the locals away
ouch what I've heard leads a bit of a
tosser I'm turning marriage counselor
you can't run around like [__] Shrek
in a frock you've got to have some form
of control otherwise this restaurant
will self-destruct ding ding round
[__] two
[Music]
foreign
Countryside a perfect setting for a
traditional rustic restaurant I mean
it's a dream the funny chefs have a
restaurant here phenomenal pastures
amazing Bland great support by the
locals but trying to understand the
[__] is a completely different
nightmare
yourself Welsh
you teach yourself Welsh and remember to
speak out loud
quick
no I feel [__] dim
in this green and pleasant land lies the
fish and anchor a few years back Xbox
and Mike chimanira won 700 Grand on the
pools it's allowed him to swap his fish
and chip shop for the pursuit of his
culinary dream I'd like to set a goal
of just achieving something be it like
you know just get one Michelin star you
know they put a man on the moon with no
technology you can put a man in the moon
Michelin star don't sound a very big
thing to achieve today
Mike's got a plan to make the Step Up
from the fat fryer to the cooking odd
Cuisine nicking recipes from cookbooks
used in the home including mine
Gordon Ramsay's book there Sunday lunch
Rick Stein's book Gordon Ramsay here
again I'd like to try and recreate them
or put my own slant on a lot of them
very simply turn them into something
really special and exciting but there's
a problem in this Italian stallion's
plan for Colony world domination Mike
and wife Karen who runs the front of
house just don't see eye to eye he's
trying to run up a hill with a ball and
chain around your leg you know it's
holding you back it's slowing you down
he is very critical of me and I don't
know why because I do my job and I do my
job very well but you're supposed to
work with me
yeah married for 22 years the couple's
arguments are notorious locally Mike and
Karen have even got into trouble with
the law for rounding public
[Music]
we're having a row carry it in my face
and I just pushed it out of the way you
know yeah so I shoved it back and I
screamed back and I give you a shove as
well
two-handedly these two don't just ran
with each other they also ran with the
customers it makes for a stinking
reputation and no one's coming here to
eat hemorrhaging a grand a week this
Eatery is heading for the big chopping
board in the sky oh my God
what was that down there
it can't be it can it
you can't miss that one can you
unfortunately the Germans did
hello everybody
and this is Mike yeah
Mike who's in love with blue blue yeah
[__] me you can't miss it can you how
are you all right thanks good do we know
you're so short well short and Powerful
yep hey
on you I know you in love with blue as
much as Mike no no no thanks for that
Ronaldo Zola [__] me I didn't know
sports bars existed in the middle of
Wales it's bright it's ghastly and uh
yeah
it's blue
and another addition to this Hall of
Fame is me a fish recipe for one of my
cookbooks using monkfish is on the menu
board
it's quite Airy when you see your own
food on somebody else's menu it's for
the home cook at home not in a [__]
restaurant
this menu is a mishmash of cookbook
recipes it's so vast I'm dizzy reading
it now I'll start with the soup first my
darling please thank you first off I'm
not to the great Georgia locatelli very
chunky isn't it yes
foreign
[Music]
next up let's see how my fish recipe
stands up he's got the black dream with
a basil and peabon Femme I've changed
that I still use the bond Femme but I
roast fillet of monkfish
lots of raw monkfish is actually quite
nicely roasted finally a madagafri
tribute that well-known Welsh classic a
chicken korma Curry flying something out
of a [__] Pig's trough we had someone
in the bean to claridgeers run by Gordon
Ramsay and they thought that they
enjoyed their food here a lot more than
what they enjoyed it there for
Welsh not
we'd only see dessert
[Music]
happy to be here yeah just arrived sat
down went through the menu you've got
everything and anything on there part of
it comes from I see something and I like
the look of it I want to put it on the
menu but the menu reads like a trophy
show well I know it's gone you've gone
around and picked up all these little
bits of like a [__] Magpie yeah
trophy trophy trophy stick it on stick
it on stick it on yeah I was really
excited about the [__] soup when the
super Rose just like a mush of [__]
vegetables a Gunk it was shocking the
monkfish even the slots were like raw
Mike they weren't even cooked so it was
like a raw onion and then the biggest
kick in the bollocks was the [__]
Curry that was shocking was that Lloyd
Grossman's sauces no no there's a sauce
Uncle Ben's oh yeah but that's what
hurts causes more damage serving that I
like your [__] passion that's clearly
there but you're not a chef not
and that menu is full of your wish list
yeah
with no customers it's obvious the
fishing Anchor's reputation is bad time
to turn detective to see just how bad
fishing anchor
their clues in cyberspace recently
posted reviews the food has to be the
best I've ever eaten home or abroad
here's another one I've been to Rick
Steins and I've been to Gordon Ramsay
but to find a place better than them on
my doorstep is a dream come true Mike
Burns strange the reviews are good so
good that there's something fishy going
on here there's three reviews all
written by a guy called Mike he's been
to Rick Stein's he's been to Gordon
Ramsay's it's all a little bit too
familiar to find a better place than
them on my doorstep is a dream come true
a little fat [__]
truthfully okay and you you you don't
[__] lie to me now nor you Michael
Burns yeah I don't get excited about
food too often and having died at Rick
Stein and Gordon Ramsay's I think I
found a better restaurant in West Wales
long live the fishing anchor recommended
Mike Burns
Afghanistan
where Dash I don't that's Daniel's
friend in that thing Mike
truthfully yeah and I know the truth
which one of these three did you post on
there
this one thank you why
we just wanted to we we spoke to someone
and they say people do these things and
take the time to get themselves noticed
and that's that's what we've done can
you blow torch them put some Icy sugar
on there [__] caramelize them or put
them in the [__] bin thank you
professional cooking is a much much much
tougher job than people I might think so
you can't just go Nick recipes from
cookbooks and hey Presto I'm a chef and
then write your own [__] reviews he's
a sitting disaster waiting to happen
tonight I've pressed gang some reluctant
locals into eating here I need to see
how Mike handles cooking for a full
restaurant it's such a large menu like
that I spent nightmare no
it is the customers wait long for food
not usually
Mike's confident I'm not his menu is
made up of cookbook recipes designed for
home Cooks to lovingly slave over but
for one man to try and cook them from
scratch for a restaurant is madness
[Music]
foreign
the dishes are just too complicated to
be cooked quickly Mike's running around
like a headless chicken
oh [__]
[Music]
[__] me you're doing it the hard way
what's there right now Mike is obviously
not a [__] Chef he should be cooking
for three full tables at the same time
he's not he's only cooking for one so
it's like watching my mum at home
cooking for a dinner party two hours
into service and the food's just not
getting out
yeah
it's like a famine customers are staving
of hunger by eating bar snacks
with an unworkable menu for service
aspiring out of control the pressures on
this husband and wife team and these two
are going to war Mike's even got his own
Welsh Battle Cry for Karen
what's going on what do you mean what's
going on this
well what am I supposed to do they've
been there for [__] our wife
ah these tables is booked in yeah it's
[__] ridiculous
this isn't a marriage it's a battlefield
the relationship needs some serious
fixing
outside there's more trouble Brewing so
it was better for them to sit there
I'm going home I couldn't give a [__]
about your crappy buddy Pub it's an
absolute load of shine we've got a 70
year old buddy woman with us and you
haven't give me something a bloody [__]
and that's for you
yeah well don't bother coming back
today
can't believe what I'm hearing
there's no stopping this woman there's a
misunderstanding over an order Karen's
going off on one again since five
o'clock this morning yeah I've come here
especially for this
[__]
thing or leave it now I want you to
leave now because I don't want to be for
not I've had a title tonight now if you
want to swear at me again you can leave
right now
they're not being small enough
thank you
I like to spend four [__] hours
[Music]
right I'll just get in your car and go
oh dear
this is a first for me I've never ever
seen a customer chucked out a restaurant
like that before that is [__]
embarrassing and no wonder this place is
in serious trouble because that was
appalling what in the [__] have I got
myself into here
hostilities have seized almost half the
customers didn't get served tonight Mike
and Karen have gone AWOL the only things
I can get in this mad house is from a 17
year old waitress why
and all the shouting
tell me how you're feeling pissed right
off yep I got a title right yeah well I
can give two shiny shots if there's 150
people out there waiting together okay I
feel as sick as a dog because I've been
threatened I've been called an old tart
I've been called a scrubber by customers
I have never ever ever had anybody talk
in a car before what went wrong tonight
Mike is that you did one table at a time
21 we cooked four and you made it look
like 201
it's the transformation from coming out
of a cook to a chef and I can see where
you shot yourself in the foot the
[__] menu if I was in here and asked
to cook this [__] menu because you're
on your bed upstairs
ill I wouldn't even attempt to do what
you did tonight one thing okay tomorrow
even before I start looking at the menu
okay the two of you it's like you're
having a [__] boxing match in here
it's husband and wife Ryan
that has to stop tomorrow I see it all
the time when customers are frustrated
the customers King Karen
you can't [__] around with them it
spreads like wildfire
[__] me welcome to lamberta this is a
[__] nightmare turning that place
around it's gonna take me a lot longer
than [__] 12 rounds I tell you
I'm in Lampeter West Wales at the
fission anchor last night's service was
a disaster if things don't change this
place is going down period it's a
reality check but Chef owner Mike
jimeneera this Xbox is on the ropes
it is getting to know that you're not
really going in the right direction I
mean
they probably wouldn't step up from a
truck stop in reality that's glorified
I'm still not going to give up I'm still
going to keep going
you know but what
am I aim to do now is to listen walk to
God and says and absorb it all like a
sponge if like as much of it as I can
and pointed it in the right direction
just draw another deep breath and come
back out fight in
time for a bit of tough love
my opening shop in helping Mike is to
get rid of his comfort blanket those
cookbooks including mine something
that's [__] destroying you in here
you know that yeah something that is a
big problem in this kitchen yeah
these [__] things right great recipes
of the world
out Asian cooking by Uncle Ben Sunday
lunch not incision there make it easy
not interested in that Rick's time
Mediterranean not instead
come play with Jamie not interested in
that and Rick Stein's French Odyssey
bang get your coat we're going down to
the charity shop I want to give
something back to Lampeter we just
digest I don't know where they come back
[__] you know don't tell me we've had
them open the car door please for 20
years
[Music]
everything I've seen points to Mike
trying to be someone he's not mock
reviews using other people's recipes to
help him I need to find the real mic
starting with his Italian Heritage who's
that gentleman there that's my
grandfather wow uh Italian yeah yeah I
love you from where Naples and that's
his parents my great grandparents wow
again from Naples again from Naples they
were farmers just worked the land it all
pour it put the salt of Italy Paul
really yeah wow so it's quite an Italian
historic tree there and that lady is
that's my grandmother basically who I
learned you know a lot of the Italian
cooking you know basically that that's
that's who I am you know we're we're
proud of it
there's been an Italian Community in
West Wales for years Mike's passionate
about this Heritage I planned to channel
that passion induced cooking by making a
classic Italian Dish my starting point
and nearby organic vegetable farm
[Music]
anchor we need a good service tonight
yeah and we're going to come up with a
dish that can get some traffic through
the restaurant without becoming too
concentrated and stuck
I'm taking Mike back to his roots here
they grow the very Tomatoes he tasted
when he was a kid
[Music]
so what they're called These are called
San Marzano samosano and they're
specifically for making sauces when was
the last time we came picking tomatoes
mate all my grandparents for a minute
that's the last time I picked it up
ready how long ago 30 years ago or more
well these are beautiful this is like
being in a candy shop yeah absolutely
phenomenal everywhere many years since I
chases a tomato like that
[Music]
it's time for Mike to cook from his
heart and not cookbooks his
grandmother's recipe for spaghetti
meatballs explain the perfect meatball
good mince Meats yes combination of beef
and pork thyme yep parsley yep chili
Parmesan cheese
could you say it was your grandmother
inspired you how to cook would you say
that's where it started yes yeah because
you're quite a passionate little [__]
inside aren't you yeah ah yes
Mike's not a chef yet he struggles
cooking for a full restaurant these
meatballs are the first step in helping
you right the emphasis of tonight's
service is what
is to get the tables speed speed speed
yeah speed speed speed
multiple portions can be pre-prepared
and served up in a matter of minutes I
don't care whether we've got 10 books or
20 books I don't want customers waiting
but length of time again yeah
no they're gonna cook From Within Myself
find you a watch Within Myself and put
that on a plate
do me a favor rub off that [__] [__]
tikka masala balti korma crap [__]
[__] off of there yes all off one big
swipe there you go bang Karma's off yes
what's your wife's name Karen ah
ah
can you call a Karen tonight color yeah
no but can you do it in a really
affectionate way that you [__] love
her yeah as is a husband and wife team
because the minute you two start [__]
showing some form of affection and
respect everybody else follows
ah that was you grunting like a troll
looking for your [__] spanner no but
serious and I was standing there like I
said
now this guy's [__] Bonkers what's he
smoking
tonight I'm going to show Mike how
meatballs speed up service this place
looks like a sports bar so I've invited
the local Rugby Club 15 strapping Lads
and they're starving hungry
are you on halftime
we get that 15 out yeah that's over one
third of the dining room cooked for okay
come on
it's taken just minutes to serve up the
meatballs to the rugby Lads job done
[Music]
we couldn't even get 12 Stars
they're nice yeah
nice and spicy very good
I think
they look like Fighters but it taste
like meatballs it's called cuisineman
the kitchen's starting to come together
out front it's a different story the
restaurant's busy but where's Karen
sorry the two seconds please sorry buddy
thank you you're not smoking I yes or no
yes that's disgusting come on Karen
please now I need everybody's help
tonight come on please yeah ridiculous
come on
he's busting his ass off there you're
outside smoking take the order of six
please no no well you you told me two
minutes uh Karen he told you two minutes
but does that means say you've got to go
out and smoke a cigarette I thought you
were running the restaurant I am thank
you thank you dear oh dear
I'm not convinced with her this for me
is someone taking the piss like they're
just going out tonight for a [__]
game of bingo She's Gotta attack it run
it and observe it but you can't
disappear every 30 seconds for a
cigarette for a cigarette what about
customers arriving
and one of the owners outside puffing
away what kind of message is that
sending to anybody
Karen standards are sloppy and it's
showing now there's confusion over
table's order
two steaks
two plus three is five yeah plus six
yeah yeah yeah seven you're missing a
main course
we cooked exactly what you wrote
can you go and ask the lady what she
ordered please urgently
one venison in straight away please
okay let me ask you a question now yeah
without getting defensive and running
off in a strop why did you forget the
venison on the order because two people
ordered the Venison and then we'll cross
it off yeah but they could both of them
canceled it and then he and then it was
the caliber to go back on and then he
ordered the venison again you forgot to
write it on yeah tomorrow we're having a
lesson and taking orders yeah okay don't
get upset I'm not good enough we're in
the [__] we look stupid
listen let me just finish yeah by the
time that venison's cooked and rested
yeah the existing customers around the
table the fellow guests will be on
[__] desserts as a unit look stupid
please don't tell me any different
because I'm not telling you anything
don't start shouting you'll run off in a
minute and start smoking no I won't but
you're always in the garage to give
bloody
[Music]
we look stupid yeah yes I do
we know
you don't get it do you yes yes you
don't get it oh God
[Music]
that's all you said you're gonna run
away now no I'm not customer's gonna
hear you customers can hear you and they
can hear you as well
is this what it's like
she forgets to write a Venison and then
shouts and screams and runs off
close the door
let's stop the embarrassment further
I'll talk tonight
I've heard what you said
what I was trying to say to her is there
any ways you can recommend a meatball
that's cooked so we can get it out
quickly rather than cooking the Venice
we have a chance to get it up yeah I
can't even get a [__] virgin edgeways
at eight o'clock this evening I'm
sweating my bollocks off trying to get
this place up to speed and she's outside
having a cigarette
huh
ding ding round [__] two
[Music]
listen to me you're doing the same
you're not listening to me it seems you
don't listen to him
you're doing it now you're doing it now
you're not letting me finish like you
wouldn't let him finish
you do it again you do it again what he
was gonna say after he finished said he
was done the next thing he's gonna say
is I tell you what why don't you try and
get the Salem the last meatballs to get
it out for the night but you didn't give
a chance because bang you was there to
throw it again so I'd like you to get
behind the bar where you should be and
get Jane up from the eyelashes not alone
behind there right
stop expect me back tomorrow
[__] off just get it done [__] off no
just get it done you can't take your car
so you can you I can't take it but I
don't like being told to [__] off
the venison
finally gets served I'm deeply concerned
yeah for the shouting and screaming
you're screwing the business and the
quicker you learn to control your temper
yeah the quicker you're going to run
your business
for the better let me finish okay but
I'm not allowed to finish anything I was
saying earlier that's what I was trying
to think
is this a competition between you and I
don't know I don't know what you want me
to say there you go again but I've I've
gone up there I've apologized
I can't do anymore
you can't run around like [__] Shrek
in a frock and then expect us to pick up
the pieces you've got to have some form
of control Karen you're more concerned
about you as opposed to committing to
the business I have not
I am not
so you might want to go along with this
might go along with it right oh so
you're throwing the towel
stop it why'd you work yourself up like
this because I've tried to tell you I've
gone out there I've apologized I can't
do any more out there let me help you
help me do one
run the dining room properly yes you can
I'm just asking you not to snap
there's 20 mistakes going on in every
restaurant across Britain every night we
have to control them your problem is one
mistake you lose the [__] plot my
dear yeah but if please calm down I am
because then we can work at it together
we finished work go outside and have a
nice cigarette thank you just some fresh
air and I'll show you that though
thank you for your help again not at all
hey we got through it you sort of come
like the [__] Italian job where the
bus is on the edge of the cliff who sort
of arrived just at the right time maybe
like that bus ready to go over get some
fresh air okay thank you
right
just bear with it right it's hard it's
all in one week right and we're gonna
get it over and done with right and
we'll be back on the right Road just get
all over and done with right don't try
and be reasonable Mike I knock her right
because if you spoke to me like what
would you ask I know that right but I
override and respect right but the value
is I have to help us put the business
right
oh
[__] me
[Music]
I'm in Lampeter West Wales at the
fishing anchor I've been here for two
nights of Madness and Mayhem with the
owners rallying with everyone they've
gone for each other
[Music]
I'm hitting the streets to find out how
Mike and Karen's rails have affected
public opinion what's the reputation
but I used to go there quite a lot but
um I got put off by the um intense
attackers here put it that way perhaps a
little bit quick tempered maybe for the
customers I think the uh the landlord
um may not always be the most cheerful
of people what I've heard and heard of
him he's a bit of a tosser if people
sort of say
oh don't go that as Archibald is going
on you just won't go there
[Music]
the fish and Anchor's reputation is rock
bottom now I've heard that Mike's got
into trouble with the law for round with
locals I'm turning marriage counselor to
make Mike and Karen realize that they're
arguing must stop if it doesn't I can't
save the fishing anchor
well I had a conviction for the public
disorder I mean not much more than a
role yeah I'm not proud of the fact that
I've done it whether they're right
you're right it doesn't matter but what
I'm trying to say in a business point of
view
we can't wash
our dirty Linen in public and I don't
know if you really understand
how bad
the reputation is the only argument that
a witnessed is here is that it's all
work related you know kitchen stuff yeah
nothing personal whatsoever absolutely
okay but what I'm trying to say is that
the you don't limit it you don't go at
it in a small manner no I understand
what you see here it's a severity of it
I keep saying to him there's people in
the bar you can you they can hear you
you're both as bad as one another I know
we are I'm just trying to say that we
have to turn the [__] Corner how
surely you want to yeah and surely you
want to
and I want to change it for the best and
you both need to work at it together and
I'll help you with that you you love
each other deep down inside but I don't
get that [__] feeling so I just want
it run by a husband and wife that are
supporting each other
yeah
I know I've got to calm down
and just don't get upset over nothing we
want the reputation as a restaurant for
ourselves to be as good as the food we
turn out you know it's just as important
and I think Gordon has made that clear
that went really well I mean I'd like to
think that they both got the message and
I think they listened and I want the
locals to understand that there's more
to the fission anchor than just [__]
arguments so that has to stop now I
can't change the reputation overnight
but what I can do is change this place
and help give a new identity and put it
back on the map in Lampeter
[Music]
my plan is to draw Mike's Italian roots
and turn the fission anchor into an
Italian restaurant first up get rid of
Mike's unworkable menu it will make
everyone's life a lot easier I've also
arranged some temporary help from the
local catering college to get a new menu
up and running can I introduce you
somebody this is Kelly yes yes Kelly
Karen Mike this is Kelly hello hey to
make things faster and easier for you I
want you to open up and work with Kelly
I've designed a streamlined Italian menu
especially for Mike six starters six
Mains and three desserts except there's
two of you here tonight and we go
together the bass salmon monkfish prawns
and shallots the garlic it's rustic easy
fish too
foreign this new menu is idiot proof
he'll be able to cook top quality rustic
dishes easily and quickly these tiger
prawns in a tablespoon of pesto our pine
nuts Homer drain off our pasta and look
we're away we're not [__] running
over there one over there for sure
these dishes will fly out of the kitchen
it will make for a less pressurized
service
and no stress will help Mike and Karen
stop rowing so it's literally two
minutes to put that dish together you
could do that while they cleared it
absolutely
the most important thing from the menu
is the speed with which we can put
everything together I mean it's
completely
defuse any problems or stress and
strains within the kitchen of having to
try and you know unlike the old menu
trying to achieve something that's
almost unachievable if seasonal stress
in the kitchen We're not gonna be
arguing because he's not screaming and
sheltered at me and I haven't got
nothing to shouted him back
I've got more than the menu to fix the
key to any restaurant success is
creating a welcoming atmosphere
meeting Karen is like coming face to
face with an uptight Welsh Dragon
she's got to relax
sometimes when you go to the table your
face honestly I mean the only thing is
missing is a wasp you know I swear to
God you're like that it's intense and
it's like
I want you to relax with him
brave souls are volunteered to act as
guinea pig customers it'll allow me to
observe carrying the waitresses closely
and lend a helping hand have you been
with us before how was your first time
I can't see bus y waitresses and had a
Mena shine professional courteous
Karen's turn
she's like the ice Maiden completely
Frozen
[Music]
time for a pep talk when the customers
come in greet them as if you need them
yes don't kiss their ass no make them
feel welcome
take two
she's talking she's listening but she's
scary
chef
he's not the husband he's the old man
yes
I was testing you all not to make you
look stupid but to make the service
friendlier so we're not like this like
we're still yeah what do you want
yeah what do you want what do you
recommend you've got such a lovely smile
when you're in the dining room people
want to see you in here push it yes
the day of the relaunch of the new fish
and anchor but before it can be an
Italian restaurant the awful sports bar
Decor has to go I want to bring a breath
of fresh air in here we're leaning
towards something in connection with
your grandparents Italian so it's you
know a country fair it's warm it's
rustic and it's it's inviting
let's go while she's in the good mood
yeah should we get it going yeah just in
case she turns yeah catch that smile
yeah it's like the eclipse comes around
once every four years
a fresh start for the fishing anchor
this new look will help make for a
relaxed atmosphere perfect for welcoming
back customers
like a breath of fresh air that's what
happens sometimes you will go on the
wrong road and you can't see it can't
see the woods for the trees finally
Mike's free of his unworkable menu just
by getting rid of what was on that wall
that board and removing that from my
life has been like lifting the world off
my shoulders
time to unveile the new look to the
waitresses and Haddad and Mena John John
has the blue look at the carpet
oh it's fresh it's fresh and cheerful
with the restaurant sorted it's time to
deal with the most crucial bit of the
relaunch winning the trust of the people
of Lampeter I've arranged a ride into
town to promote the new fishing anchor
[Applause]
right
look at you
Building Bridges we're down off to
Lampeter yes we're gonna get the message
out there
I'm gonna shout from the rooftops the
style yes what you're doing where it's
coming from why we're doing it and we're
going to build some bridges and the
reputation is going to be changed yes
leaflets hay bales canapes get your ass
in there
[Applause]
it's the start of a long road to
rebuilding this place's reputation get
down to the fishing anchor fantastic
rustic Italian food
[Music]
Mike needs to rub shoulders with the
locals and he's using his meatballs to
win them over
lovely get down to the fishing anchor
delicious meatballs wonderful pastas
with no Italian restaurants in Lampeter
there's plenty to shout about a classy
menu and a new look and most important a
friendlier service I can't confirm the
cameras we need to stop
out she loves you all
if Mike and Karen start round tonight
they'll undo all the hard work so I've
got a plan if they get stressed rather
than tearing strips off each other I'm
introducing an anger management prop
right services are quite stressful yes
tonight if we get straighted you and you
on the naughty step bang over there
off you go
get in there Big Boy come on get some
Willy behind it can care if we don't get
knocked out there's one big one good
girl well done well done well done well
done no
so you take it out on that yes and you
want to scream and you want to [__] off
outside for a cigarette yes take out on
that
okay how are we feeling
good yes excited how are you feeling
calm calm collect it yeah I'm excited
okay good right in front of your eyes
on that chair is your Chef's jacket
for a man that's [__] in his late 40s
that's been busting his ass off for the
last 20 years this is your chance this
is your time now take advantage of it
and [__] do it properly more
importantly enjoy it
gonna look like
the Reckoning the relaunch of the new
fishing anchor this is the biggest fight
of Mike's life for this xboxer it
carries the promise of a huge reward to
finally call himself a chef
the people of Lampeter are coming to
give the fishing anchor a second chance
a golden opportunity for Mike and Karen
to redeem this place's reputation
[Music]
feeling like a professional setup with
Mike taking control like a chef you call
the girls ready for service
new menus doing its job with this is
flying out of the kitchen and going down
well it looks quite simple quite plain
in that respect
it's lovely
out front waitresses and Mena are
keeping the orders rolling in crucially
Karen's Charming the guests
[Music]
just two days ago she was shouting at
anyone in earshot now she's like a new
woman smiling chatting welcoming
the restaurant's now at its capacity
Mike's under pressure
[Music]
starters and table four clears oh Mike
give me an answer please
just check now the orders are stacking
up and he's panicking
you're going too fast listen stop this
is where it really seriously matters now
I'm still unconvinced that this guy can
do more than one table at a [__] time
the menu is so idiot-proof
straightforward easy country Italian
fare and he's [__] stressing out out
front the food isn't hitting the tables
quickly enough
we'll be drunk before the food comes
yeah
I'm starving hungry and working all day
and there's nothing happening it's just
graceful and [__] I'm just not
getting saucepans not dead under there
I'm going to have to use the same
saucepan over and over Mike's teaching
on the edge
dresses where's the dressing gone this
doesn't bode well for the future later
grab some spoons big spools I'm gutted
[Music]
and then the Knight takes an unexpected
turn watch out watch out
waitress Manor has slipped on the floor
she's unconscious it could be serious is
called the night service stops she
doesn't want to see like that right
stand up I need the food thing out of
the way
uh what's that ending um
bad fall she slept on the floor and hurt
her back slight seizure
and went into some form of shock
taking away an ambulance um thankfully
her parents were there she stayed really
calm and she's in safe hands I'm
convinced she's going to be absolutely
fine but
it was a tough night
[Music]
I'm back in West Wales it's a month
since the fishing Anchor's reopening
night ended so abruptly when waitress
Mena slipped and was taken to hospital
she recovered and went home the next day
[Music]
first of all I'm very relieved the fact
that men are is back to 100 Fitness I'm
dying to find out what's actually going
on in the fishing anchor because on the
launch night we were halfway through and
just struggling to keep our neck above
the waters has he changed back to his
old ways and we've got a problem with
each other I hope they're not washing
their dirty Linen in front of their
customers I don't [__] believe it
he's painted the bloody thing it looks
inviting that's one bit of good news
hey hello how are you okay it looks
great out there how are you my darling
very good
yes my new turn around and look at a
Blackboard nope nope no no written menu
written menu style of food is half Rick
Stein half Gary Rhodes no it's Italian
figure wise where are we comparison to
last year well uh customers with doubly
among the customers double among the
covers yeah and there's a pause for
something like a four four and a half
Grand loss with uh broke even this month
that's good news that's very very
positive yeah rowing stopped stopped
must have been one somewhere
no no no we've taken Venice off the menu
now anyway yeah yeah yeah
I look at Venice in a completely
different [__] way now I don't know
about you
a month ago Mike and Karen's constant
Rouse were driving the customers away I
can't believe they're completely stopped
a quick flick through the reservations
book gives me a hotline to recent
customers now I just want some [__]
uh background time to find out whether
Mike and Karen have truly built Bridges
with the locals hello is that Roger hi
it's Gordon Ramsay how are you
what was the food like
let's feel like in the dining room
good and the million dollar question was
there any arguing
one nil to the fishing anchor so is that
Sue yeah how was dinner
was the service warm anybody shout at
you
no no I'm just asking two nil hi Tony
it's Gordon you sneaked into the fishing
anchor recently
ten of you they serve 10 main courses
all the same time yeah you didn't have
to take a two-week holiday in between
courses
[__] three nil there's got to be some
negativity somewhere do you hear any
shouting screaming
well no I'm just asking you the customer
you are the critic thank you my darling
big kiss for me it tells me the
reputation is spreading and it's
spreading in a very positive way
the word's good seeing is believing
Mike's a changed man a month ago he's
running around the kitchen like a
headless chicken now he's mastered my
menu big boy can finally call himself a
chef congratulations
the dishes are flying out oh my God so
quick
I hope
and he's in control of his kitchen
where's all these orders in
girls
and then I hear either you're screaming
for orders yeah these are going oh no in
a minute and I got nothing to get on
with out front the atmosphere is exactly
what I was aiming for relaxed and
welcoming I'm good darling you can come
again now I'm a little bit nervous
yeah yeah well it's going really well
you know he's got five tickets on yeah
there's Harmony everybody's smiling the
cousin's happy what's going on nothing
well the change in him is um
unbelievable he's proud of himself again
yeah yeah forgetting things done and
quickly and nobody's complaining you
look very relaxed I am I'm enjoying
myself actually good you know those
cookbooks we got rid of they're gone
they've gone they went to a good cause
yeah now I think it's about time yeah
you put your own book together
here we go yeah not too sure about your
sous chef look at it carefully and then
start filling out your own rustic
recipes and cook from here yeah cook
from the heart yeah and then print it
and flog it
put it alongside yours on the Shelf see
how we go take care
I think me and make the reassessed I'm a
marriage I really really feel like going
on anymore again you know just go me and
him going away for a sloppy
Daft weekend somewhere
so we may just do that really happy to
see it actually working and for me the
most important thing is we've fixed the
menu that means we've fixed Mike and
Karen and if they can stick to that
they've got a happy restaurant happy
customers and more importantly a happy
couple
I've never had a facial before I had
these lines at 21 so what's the pointing
in a facial Karen do you snore yes you
do
bottom burp no never ever ever do
Karen is that your tummy what is that my
Googling plug hole
[Music]
so relaxing